hey guys today it is the first of sep
tember my name is just and here's a
bunch it's official hadera kojima is in
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
effect that probably shouldn't surprise
you in what is far from his first
appearance in the Metal Gear series
today Okajima can be recruited as a
mother based worker in the phantom pain
mother base is essentially your hub of
operations where you can assign various
tasks just soldiers captured in game the
cameo was discovered by gamespot video
producer Edmund Tran also known as the
guy behind a camera right now he posted
two pictures to Twitter that show off
kojima's character as a special
volunteer in mother base kijima
specialty appears to be Intel with an
s-rank rating and an A+ rank for
research and development skills
apparently kajima will only join you if
you previously saved him during a
special side quest in ground zeroes as
it is explained by mother base manager
kazu Kira Miller that characters you
rescue there will join mother base
Microsoft has released a 4 to 6 demo
ahead of the game's release on xbox one
on sep tember 15 those of you in Europe
and North America will be able to access
the 12.6 gigabyte demo which includes a
small selection of the 460 cars that
will be available in the final game
you'll also get to check out features in
the game such as working cockpits damage
modeling wet weather and night racing
effects the demo will run at 1080p and
60 frames per second developer turn 10
studios have said that the game's career
mode can reach up to 70 hours of play
and finally according to EA a beta for
star wars battlefront is on its way to
pc ps4 and xbox one in early October the
beta will give you access to battle
fronts massive 40 player mode Walker
assault on the hot map as well as a
survival mission and a new mode called
drop zone which you have said they will
explain in the weeks preceding the beta
the survival mission takes place on
tatooine where you'll play as the rebels
trying to push back the
aerial forces the beta will also let you
play as Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker I
have one that all progress including
achievements characters and status
indicators will not carry forward to the
full game and that you may encounter
some bugs EA also announced the
battlefront companion experience which
will let you view your stats and
customize your loadouts and will feature
a strategic card game called base
command you can access the companion
experience either on the web or through
your iOS or Android device battlefront
will launch on November 17 let me know
down in that comment section if you're
more excited to play the 4 to 6 demo or
to get into the Battlefront beta you can
add the games but we've got stories on
Metal Gear 5 server issues and our mad
max review roundup that is everything I
wanted to tell you about today to let me
know in that comment section what
mattered to you and I'll catch the same
time summer